hey 42 here I previously talked about
deadly computer viruses such as Stuxnet
and the world's most-wanted hacker kevin
Mitnick but i personally think it's
really interesting and concerning the
immense damage a hacker can do to some
of the world's largest companies and
organizations over the course of just
one hack so today we look at the biggest
hacks in history and I can't think of a
more appropriate starts than a young
Cuban born American who masterminded the
largest credit card fraud in history
Albert Gonzalez by 40 the naturally
gifted Gonzales carried out his first
known successful hack into a
little-known government agency called
NASA this was only two years after he
got his first computer early in his
career
Gonzalez dove headfirst into the world
of credit-card fraud by involving
himself of a hacking group called shadow
crew shadowcrew comm was a form of
operating between 2002 and 2004 where
people could buy and sell stolen credit
card details it was ended when the US
Secret Service busted wide open and made
several arrests Gonzalez avoided prison
time by turning informant and providing
incriminating evidence on his fellow
shadow crew members to the Secret
Service but karma came back to bite
Gonzalez when he was indicted in 2009
for carrying out what is still to this
day the largest breach of payment card
information in history the hack was
against Heartland Payment Systems which
processed credit and debit card
transactions for over 275,000 US
businesses millions of transactions
passed through their servers each day
this was a sophisticated plan which
Gonzalez branded operation get rich or
die trying' gonzales along with a
hacking accomplice known as Petey who
later turned out to be Daymond Patrick
Joey discovered a vulnerability in
Heartland Payment system
which enabled them to perform an SQL
injection attack on the company's
database an SQL injection is when a
nefarious command is unexpectedly fed to
a database which it isn't expecting and
usually causes that database to either
leak information back to the hacker or
destroys data completely Gonzales also
found the same vulnerability in the
payment systems of 711 JCPenney t.j.maxx
and target he also installed a packet
sniffer on the networks which recorded
credit card transactions in real time
including the mag stripe data from the
cards happening across thousands of
stores nationwide every day from these
companies gonzales who had the online
pseudonym of soup nazi was able to steal
a combined total of over 170 million
credit card numbers instantly giving it
on-demand access to probably more money
than almost everyone alive what did he
do with his newfound access to unlimited
stolen wealth he threw himself a $75,000
birthday party and lived in and out of
lavish hotels for a while though it is
thought that he was acting as a hacking
cell for a Russian kingpin so much of
the money was transferred back to Russia
via Western Union
The Secret Service finally managed to
indict Gonzalez in 2009 and who is
handed two concurrent 20-year prison
sentences after his arrest he informed
agents of a barrel buried in his parents
garden containing 1.2 million dollars in
cash contrary to Albert Gonzales our
next hacker wasn't motivated by riches
in his own words he hacked two of the
world's most secure and secretive
organizations for thought Jonathan James
was born in Miami and became infatuated
with computers when he was six by 16 he
was going by the online pseudonym
comrade and had his eyes set on one of
the grandest conceivable hacking
trophies
the US Department of Defense
specifically James found a vulnerability
on the service of the defense Threat
Reduction agency DTRA an arm of the DoD
responsible for monitoring potential
threats to the security of the United
States which is really ironic James
managed to install a backdoor on one of
the DTRA servers located in dual
Virginia with the backdoor in place he
could place a sniffer on the server
recording all traffic that passed
through it on a daily basis since DTRA
employees access the server every day he
was able to capture the username
passwords and private messages of
hundreds of DoD employees this gave him
the keys for some of the government's
most critical secret systems and made
him privy to state secrets that even
White House staff were not aware of
never mind a 16 year old in his bedroom
another system that James gained
unauthorized access to after performing
a separate hack on the Marshall Space
Flight Center was the code that NASA
used to operate the climate of the
International Space Station in theory
this meant that James could alter the
temperature and humidity levels of the
ISS from his bedroom only a few months
after this Huck James was arrested and
still only 16 became the first teenager
to be imprisoned for cyber crime he was
sentenced to seven years but was
permitted to serve them at home -
internet access of course due to his age
and low risk to public safety
sadly Jonathan James's story ends in
tragedy in 2008 he committed suicide
because he convinced himself that the
police were going to wrongly charge him
through involvement in the Albert
Gonzalez TGX case we're not broke now
during the Internet's short life there
have been endless hacks that have stolen
usernames passwords and other sensitive
information from large websites some of
the most notable examples being Yahoo
Facebook eBay uber Sony and varisai
whilst these attacks were
huge in their scope yahoo had nearly
three billion user records stolen not
one of those had the impact of what many
consider to be the most damaging hack in
history for millions of people all
around the world I'm of course talking
about the infamous 2015 Ashley Madison
hack in case you don't know Ashley
madison.com
is a dating website with a twist you
join with the sole intention of cheating
on your partner or spouse their official
tagline is life is short have an affair
surely nobody would use such a website
you may be thinking ah well that's not
what a staggering 32 million people
around the world thought who had signed
up to cheat on their not so significant
over on the 12th of July 2015 employees
of avid life the company that owns
Ashley Madison logged onto their
computers to find a warning message that
threatened to release the information of
every Ashley Madison user to the public
unless avid life took down Ashley
Madison website and its sister site
established men bizarrely this warning
message was accompanied by the audio of
EC DC's thunderstruck it will later
emerge that the name of the group or
individual who carried out the attack
went by the name impact team a week
after the attack avid life had still not
caved and so impact team posted a public
message online that gave the company an
ultimatum shut down your site in 30 days
or we release all of the user
information to the public following this
fret Ashley Madison tweeted that they
had patched the vulnerabilities on their
service that allowed impact team to gain
access in the first place but it was too
late
the damage had already been done if what
the hacker claimed was true and it was
he had already downloaded the personal
information of over thirty two million
Ashley Madison accounts 30 days later
the websites Wistar live so in a
pastebin post titled times up
hacking group published the first ten
gigabytes of information including
millions of email addresses used to sign
up for Ashley Madison accounts more data
dumps came and by August 60 gigabytes of
user information had been published by
the hackers online for everyone to see
this included email addresses physical
addresses and the last four digits of
credit card numbers of course people all
over the world combed through the
mountain of Records and found Ashley
Madison accounts owned by numerous CEOs
celebrities and politicians search
engines even sprung up which allowed one
to enter their spouses email address and
see if they had ever used Ashley Madison
the Ashley Madison hack was like no
other because it spawned an important
public debate sure cheating is wrong but
was it morally right of the hackers to
expose so many people in such at the
basing public manner especially when the
consequences were so tragic the two
Canadians committed suicide as a result
of their personal information being
included in the attack be causing their
personal lives to fall apart people all
over the world began receiving death
threats because of their involvement
with the site and many detestable
individuals entirely unrelated to impact
team took to extorting people they found
within the breach data by threatening to
tell that person's family if they didn't
hand over a mountain of bitcoins as for
Ashley Madison well it will perhaps
never entirely recover its public image
of a website that encourages adultery
can never have a public image in the
first place at least a positive one but
you would be surprised at how quickly
people are willing to forgive and forget
the website is still is active as ever
and they have reportedly signed up 30
million new users since the hack
perhaps that simply a testament to
people's unwavering desire to have a
shag on the side it would only be
appropriate to end on the compelling
story of a man who at least colloquially
holds DHE
of perpetrating the biggest military
hack of all time online he's known
simply as solo in reality he is 53 year
old Gary McKinnon from Glasgow a systems
administrator who made the world's most
powerful security agencies look utterly
hopeless between February 2001 and March
2002 McKinnon hacked into 97 US military
and NASA computers 97 rogue states that
rhyme with minor and Musha literally
longed millions of hacking attempts
against the Pentagon and other US
military installations every single day
they really do even though the Pentagon
wouldn't be shouting about it of these
attempts were successful IT experts
think that they almost never are yet a
Glasgow man who operated from a small
room in his girlfriend's aunt's house
bypassed America's most secure systems
with ease over and over again
furthermore McKinnon wasn't paid to hack
and he wasn't doing it to extort the US
government no you see McKinnon was a
major conspiracy fanatic and he
performed the hacks to find evidence for
his belief that the US was purposely
suppressing unlimited free energy
sources and evidence of UFO encounters
he didn't find any material that we know
of however the US authorities claimed
that whilst he was inside their systems
McKinnon deleted critical operating
system files which shut down 2000
defense computers and related systems
for 24 hours but his most spectacular
move was leaving a message on the US
military's website that read your
security is crap he also left the
following warning on one US military
computer u.s. foreign policy is akin to
government sponsored terrorism these
days it was not a mistake that there was
a huge security stand down on September
11 last year I am so low
I will continue to disrupt at the
highest levels after his arrest in 2002
McKinnon became the subject of a debate
which put a small fracture in the US UK
special relationship the white house
demanded McKinnon to be extradited to
the US to stand trial over there but in
a landmark move the then Home Secretary
Theresa May denied his extradition
keeping MacKinnon on British soil it's
believed the fact that he had Asperger's
weighed in on the decision after a
10-year legal battle it was decided in
2012 that MacKinnon would not face
charges in the UK Eva due to a lack of
evidence and all of the evidence that
was available was held by us or
priorities anyway he now runs an SEO
consultancy business your computer and
online accounts may not require the
security of the US military but you can
have it anyway if you want it with - Li
the best way to protect yourself against
hackers spammers and over online threats
is by using the leading password manager
and all-in-one Security Suite - Lane who
will store all of your passwords in a
super safe way without ever having
access to them or allowing anyone but
you to view them - Lane creates strong
and unique passwords for all of your
online accounts and auto fills them so
you never have to click forgot password
ever again and you don't have to sweat
about the extremely rare chance that -
Lane could be breached because - lanes
safely stores and decrypt your data on
your local device only using your master
password
this means that - Lane never has access
to your personal data and any hacker
would only see random noise - Lane also
also fills your credit card information
whilst online shopping so you can make
purchases without ever having to fetch
your wallet - Lane has a built-in VPN to
encrypt your data and keep your online
activity anonymous best of all it works
on any device whether you're protecting
classified state secrets or classified
videos of your cat there is no better
way to completely lock out hackers from
your personal bubble than by using dust
Lee - Lane goes
the extra mile by alerting you of any of
your accounts or data are breached it
also has a dark web monitoring system
that will immediately let you know if
your personal information appears on the
dark web where it can be seen by hackers
or spammers from my experience - Lane is
the best all bases covered security and
time-saving tool out there if you visit
my unique promo link in the description
you can get a free premium trial of -
Layton for 30 days plus if you enter 42
it checkout you will get 10% off - Lane
premium thanks for watching and thanks
again to - Lane for sponsoring this
video don't forget to check them out
using the link below